happy 2018 everyone I'm jumping ahead in
the vlog chronology to now to let you
know what I'm up to and specifically
what I'm doing after my PhD don't worry
there are three or four vlogs yet to
come soon like filling the gap so what
am i doing after my PhD well
I'm choosing to become a science
communicator you probably have some
questions why there are plenty of jobs
for science PhD grants like me and in
fact that's probably a whole video that
I'll do in the future
but I am NOT interested in becoming rich
doing work some soulless company in the
city like I'm just not interested in
that corporate life there are
opportunities in research but the
experience my PhD taught me that
academia as I experienced it wasn't
really for me I'm not ruling out going
back to academia in the future but right
now I don't want to do a postdoc and
there are scientific jobs which would
use skills that I learned in my PhD and
will be interesting and would earn good
money and they're my second choice
because I might return to that in the
future but right now I'm in a unique
position I currently earn nearly enough
money from YouTube to do it
for a job I have a big engaged audience
I have loads of contacts in the YouTube
ecosystem but most importantly I love
making videos and educating people so
perhaps this isn't the most profitable
or easiest or even the most sensible
career to try and embark on but the
alternative if I weren't to try I think
I'd spend the rest of my life wondering
what could have been so I'm gonna take a
calculated leap into the unknown and see
if I can make this work whilst I still
can doing what in my definition being a
science communicator has a few aspects
to it one making videos the main one for
me in the past I've tried to communicate
scientific or study content to you as an
audience to varying degrees of success
and basically me being a science
communicator will mean me trying to do
that a lot more though that's not to say
that this channel is now going to
suddenly become nothing but generic
science videos this channel took off and
became what it is now because of two
series one where I flocked about being
an Oxford student and two I've loved
about being a PhD student I get that a
lot of you subscribe because you like
the way I vlog well lucky for you I
really like vlogging so I'm always gonna
make short films about my life and what
I'm up to it's just that now instead of
being about studying or about uni
they're gonna be about me trying to make
it as a science communicator and
interesting places I go and interesting
things I end up doing there's actually
some really interesting things already
lined up for this year but I'll come
back to what this change means for the
channel in just a little bit to writing
for almost all of you this will come out
of completely nowhere because I'm not
known as an author of any kind but
before I went to uni one of my key
ambitions was to become an author and at
that time I meant somebody who wrote
fiction and I'm still interested in that
idea but the process of writing my
thesis for my PhD made me realize that I
actually really like writing about
science and in particular I like writing
the background chatter that was more
intended for a general audience so I'm
interested in exploring ideas that
aren't quite right for a video in
written form maybe a blog post or maybe
even ideas that are too big for a video
and would be better suited to being a
book but again more on that in just a
little bit 3 presenting this might be
doing presenting for other YouTube
channels or for TV networks which I've
already done or possibly doing
presenting out there in the magical land
of not the internet which is something
that I really love doing in school and
love doing public speaking but this
isn't something which is going to affect
this YouTube channel so I'll move on to
number 4 streaming possibly maybe got an
idea we'll see if we'll see if this
happens this is likely a plan that will
look completely different in a year as
it turns out but either I can't do
everything I said I'd like to do or
because one part of it takes up all my
time and I don't have as diverse a
portfolio as I currently imagine that I
will but so early in my career I can't
have that thing having multiple irons in
the fire is a good idea and to see if I
can have an interesting job where I
balance lots of different roles again
this is a complete
leap into the unknown for me I've been
in education for 22 years and so I feel
a little bit institutionalized so I I
don't really know what to expect so I've
probably over thought this but in my
mind it's better to overthink something
rather than under think something when
it literally determines whether or not
you can afford to eat speaking of which
how I'm aiming to release two videos
every week on this channel one of which
will be a vlog and the other will be
what I think of as a feature video
examples of feature videos include my
video about planets in star wars crash
course cries fear my book review series
and about a million other much much more
ambitious ideas that I have not had the
time to make until now if you watch my
video about the planets in star wars and
you might recall that it was sponsored
and in the future Sun but by no means
all of my videos will contain sponsored
messages it's not gonna be every video
in fact I'm only thinking of doing one
or two sponsored videos a month but in
order for me to afford to eat and to do
this as a career there gonna be a
regular feature on this channel in the
future I want to be clear that I am not
gonna be selling this channel out to
absolutely anybody if I choose to work
with a sponsor it's because I think that
the right match for the content appears
on this channel and for you guys that
watch my videos as well as it being a
good product so the income from those
sponsor videos and the adverts which
Google places on my other videos it's
what's going to keep me afloat but in
addition to those two I'm also going to
be overhauling and expanding my patreon
for those of you who don't already know
patreon is a service where audiences can
invest in their favorite content
creators where they pledge typically a
small amount like one or two dollars a
month such that their creators can
continue to make stuff and then in
exchange the creators can offer perks to
those members of their audience who
support them beyond a certain threshold
currently my patreon is a very simple
affair where people who donate more than
five dollars a month together thank you
know in the description of every video
and people who donate more than three
dollars each month get access to my
patreon feed where I said I will be
posting exclusive content every month
however for most of the months in 2017
that
didn't happen apart from a monthly
summary of everything I've been up to
that's basically because I was just too
busy to make something new for just for
patreon with everything else that was
doing like oh I don't know my PhD so
right now I'm actually not sure what I
should be offering as perks on my
patreon if you have a suggestion of
something that you think it'd be worth
while you donating your money in
exchange for then please put them down
in the comments below it's only
worthwhile running a patreon if I can
offer you guys something you think it's
actually worth you parting with your
hard-earned money I'm not just gonna do
this to pump money from my audience it's
only worthwhile if it's two-way
interactions and so the only way to make
sure that that happens is a two-way
conversation I want to hear what you
guys would like from the patreon so
please put your ideas down in the
comments next moving on to content which
definitely isn't worth anybody's money
the wiki cast of the podcast which Dan
and I run every week about random
Wikipedia articles will be returning in
2018 and hopefully we'll actually be
doing some much for that sometime soon
keep your eyes peeled if you're
interested and in addition our shared
silly YouTube channel spongy and
electric will be seeing more content in
2018 including a much long awaited
return to careful space program more
movie reviews more gaming stuff and
generally just kind of silly content at
the moment I view it as a fun side
project but I'm including it in this
video because you know eventually it
might get good enough to actually
generate revenue but for now it's it's
just fun and then lastly something
completely new as I mentioned earlier I
want to develop my writing and start
exploring ideas that aren't quite right
for videos so sometime this year very
soon hopefully I'm gonna be launching a
website which is a hub for everything I
do so this YouTube channel sponge in
electric my research work Oxbridge
access were the wiki cast and as part of
that website there's going to be a blog
which is going to be vaguely about
science history about maths about music
and the intersections between them now I
refuse to say how regularly I'm gonna
upload on that did you upload a blog you
probably publish a blog so I'm
completely new to this but I'm hoping to
put out several posts a month
if I could get to weekly that would be
great but that that's a pipe dream I am
really quite excited about the block
though and trying to mix it in with
everything else that I do question is
when now
I've had that in my PhD thesis which
means that I can now concentrate fully
for the first time in my life on making
interesting content I do still have to
set my Viper
which is an oral exam where I defend my
research which takes place in February
but apart from that small tiny
insignificant I mean it's a small I
barely even thinking about it's not
continue my life at all thing this is my
job which means you guys are my bosses
now I am only able to consider doing
this as a job because you guys like
watching and listening to and hopefully
soon reading the stuff that I make and I
want to be clear that I am fully aware
of that so when I say you guys are my
bosses I I really mean it I have a
simple rule when it comes to making
content and that's that it has to make
the universe better in some way now I
get why other people are content making
just generic banal content that is
literally designed to waste people's
time and to push low quality merch but
that's that's not what I'm about that's
not what I'm interested in doing because
I'm in a really privileged position not
just do this as a career I'm in a really
privileged position to make a difference
in the world the single most important
thing a person can do for the world is
to educate others to make them
interested in it in a way that they
weren't before and to encourage them to
learn themselves because the most
dangerous thing in the world is
ignorance ignorance leads to hatred and
it leads to decisions which are later
regretted I am in a privileged position
right now to make the world a little bit
better and my work goal for 2018 is to
make the most of that position and
hopefully do it well enough that I can
earn a living doing it and I'd be
honored if I could have you guys along
for the journey if you want to support
me in this work then please subscribe to
this YouTube channel and can
supporting me on patreon and thank you
so much to everyone who's already done
so if you'd like to help even further
than the best thing you can do is to
share my videos particularly educational
ones when they come out on social media
yes I do have a pretty moderate number
of subscribers now but my videos only
gets sent to so many people if you post
a Twitter or to Reddit that really helps
get the message out there okay that got
very heavy at the end there sorry about
that
I mean well I don't apologize because I
really do believe all of this stuff but
thank you very much for watching this
video if you liked the vision for where
I'm taking this channel and my kind of I
guess my philosophy about making videos
then do please drop a like on this video
comment below with your suggestions for
what perks I could offer on my patreon
and thank you very very much for
watching I'll see you in the next one
very soon
[Music]